greetings everyone the site you're gonna
be hearing about today decide 3408 psych
class get a psych command protocols come
to side 34 away relax and it's elegant
containment cells improve yourself in
its world-class testing chambers site
3408 welcomes you come to psych 34 and
wait site description psych 3408 is the
latest resort day spa and containment
facility to be opened by the fine people
of the SCP foundation located on the
sunny beaches of redacted california
psych 3408 is our most technologically
advanced endeavor yet specially built to
cater to every mean and desire of the
anomalous community around the world as
the weight of living in a world of
normalcy been dragging you down come to
psych 3408
where all your worries and cares will be
swept away by our professionally trained
containment specialists spend your days
in style and comfort waited on hand and
foot and or other appendage type 24/7
365 chika relaxing dip in one of our
seven Olympic sized swimming pools each
one filled with its own unique illiquid
and mini ecosystem to provide the
greatest compatibility with our guests
various biological means if the most
comfortable sleep of your life or on
life on our individually constructed
cots custom-built to fit your precise
body plan visit for a day or visit for a
life visit Liguria site 34 wait do you
ever feel like the rest of the world
simply doesn't understand your art come
to site 34 away which has accommodated
some of the greatest and artists of the
world
has ever seen or not safe here you will
be provided with state-of-the-art
containment Studios in which to produce
truly cool masterpieces to your heart's
content you'll never have to worry about
your latest painting or sculpture
breaking space-time or taking the lives
to those around you thanks to the
patented triple titanium brand security
lining built into every service it's
like very floral it is your religion
scorned or feared by the non-anomalous
masses don't worry psych 34 light treats
all religions equally whether you follow
the teachings of the grand carcass I on
the technical documents of McCain the
sexual rights of the Scarlet King the
soul rending screams of the patterns
while the humble qex of the mighty spank
Oh flex our team in the department of
religion philosophy and mysticism is
ready and waiting to listen to you the
testing chambers at Cyclery correlate
are always open and our staff are and
are eager to see what new lungs straw
city your beliefs and rituals can summon
feeling a bit peckish psyche 3408
world-famous chefs are on call around
the clock to serve all your dietary
needs directly to yourself their
specialities include the finest Brenda
steaks perfectly braised chard the
thinnest of gruel pastes raw flesh
called fruit virtually any species and
much more here at site 3408 the D&D
class stands for delicious have you ever
felt that me to simply get away from the
null we here at site 3408 greatly value
the privacy of our clientele from the
moment your reservation is booked our
loyal and dedicated containment crew
will work tirelessly to ensure your stay
will never be interrupted by the pesky
worries of debt collectors telemarketers
call workers
friends family
or other loved ones making things fun is
their motto that they accomplish just
that by using the latest breakthroughs
and amnestics and the information
control technology to keep you in
perfect wonderful isolation once you've
arrived this site 3408 the outside world
will never be able to find you pounce
aside 3408 it's like 3408 welcomes you
come to suck 3408 site 3408 needs to
continue conscious i 3408
please psych 34 awaiting needs to
fulfill its primary function please
Tom's azide 30 far away please
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andre Bessette
dr. mortis Cody tench Pierce M Hamlin
sighs Savin actual rebellion fidelia's
untie verbal if you would like a
personalized thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volga thank you
you